okay we're gonna get a little bit more
detail about how to sharpen images
here's microfluidic devices that we saw
before in the flatbed scanner section I
cropped a larger picture and as we zoom
in we're actually seeing some Newton
rings which we're not loving but let's
pretend that they're not there you know
that we're going to get Newton rings
when you put glass on top of glass or
this is PDMS which is also going to give
us some newton rings so let's just take
an area maybe around here just to pay
attention I'm going to zoom in a little
more your eyes should focus around here
and around the numbers and maybe over
here to see what happens when we sharpen
we go to the filter we go down to
sharpen and use unsharp mask there are
all kinds of things but for our purposes
unsharp mask is the way to go and it was
already set at 128 once before let's go
down to almost very little sharpening it
almost kind of the the original image
and watch as I increase the amount of
sharpening you're seeing more and more
getting sharp but unfortunately what
also happens is you get a lot of the
dirt in sharpening as well and we'll
discuss that in a moment a little bit
but we're going to go at length about
cleaning images for example if I
accepted this with 228 which is
considerably sharper than before let me
undo it with command Z that was without
sharpening that's with sharpening I hope
you're seeing look over here now without
sharpening with sharpening so we're
getting some real clarity here which i
think is what we want to show but as I
said we are also getting some junk which
if I
decided to get rid of let's say with it
healing brush a little bit here get rid
of this get rid of this this is making
the image cleaner the question is am i
permitted to do this and we're going to
have a very important deeper discussion
about how much we can in fact enhance
scientific images for the time being
let's leave it at this and we're going
to save the image and clearly indicate
that this has been sharpened and that's
it there you go